Everyone in mine is the true George.The one who always comes in for a
long time is Louis IX
.
It's fine to have the Amaris gun snooped on,
General. I
'm telling you all the truth, so don't worry. Let me
introduce you to George.
These two are my son and his daughter-in-law.
I don't have to retort that it's okay,
it'll open a wound, so stop
[music]
I didn't know
that the old man had a son.
After that, I
won't have any regrets if I show my grandson's face that I'll be able to see him alive again.
Young people are hesitant,
this is
me dee dee
I've finished that hesitance and it's over 4 I'm not going to let
this old man's invitation down
[Music]
Well, I
'm sorry.
It's good, isn't it small?